next year the cdc's eviction moratorium
uh has expired that was the rule
passed down by our overlords of the cdc
saying that landlords
are not allowed to evict people who
don't pay their rent
now how in the hell does the cdc have
the authority
to make a policy how do they have the
authority to make any policy
let alone a housing policy well nobody
ever quite explained that
the cdc never explained where they get
this authority from but they found it
or rather they just claimed it that's
what tyrants do they say oh you know
that's what do you mean authority i have
the authority because i'm doing it
that's why i have it um
and so that was the policy had been in
place for months now and then it expired
congress didn't extend it and now the
socialist wing of the democrat party
which is
otherwise known as the entire democrat
party is playing the blame game um first
here's aoc a few nights ago
in the middle of the night saying that
she was marching to the capitol to
demand that the moratorium
be extended this this i think is pretty
frightening this is kind of an
insurrection that she
you might say that she conducted on her
own let's watch this
hello from washington
it is about 11 24 right now
and i am walking to the capitol because
congress is allowed is about to allow
the national eviction moratorium to
expire
at midnight tonight and
they're forced the moratorium to expire
before
the emergency rental assistance money
has gotten out
to renters and mom-and-pop landlords
and so i'm heading out over there
because sister corey bush has called
for us to come out there and call on
congress to bring their buds back
so that we can vote to extend moratorium
it's not just me
and it's not just representative bush
but we've done a call
and lots of everyday people
are starting to show up on the capitol
steps
that we extend the victim moratorium
because the
alternative is to allow almost 11
million
people to be at risk of eviction
starting midnight tonight
look at that that is uh that's that's
terrible
storming the capital an insurrection
it's worse than 911 honestly um
but it's the the eviction moratorium
she's saying it's coming to an end
people are going to be
evicted it's going to be crisis across
the country
and that might actually happen where
where lots of people lose their housing
because they've been told for the last
many months that they don't have to pay
their rent and
and that was never gonna last forever it
couldn't last forever
and so by giving people waving your
magic wand
and giving millions of people the right
quote-unquote to not pay their rent you
have set them up for this aoc
you've set them up for what's about to
happen
but we should say if she was on cnn
later after storming the capital and um
and
conducting this insurrection the
insurrectionist was on cnn
talking about this and she doesn't blame
the republican party she actually blames
the democrats let's watch that
democrats control the house you guys
control the senate you guys control the
white house
nothing aggressive was done by
leadership uh
until just a couple days ago who's to
blame here
well you know i think there's a couple
of of issues here first of all
you are absolutely correct in that the
house and house leadership have the
opportunity to vote to extend the
moratorium
and there were many and there was
frankly a handful of
conservative democrats in the house that
threatened to get on planes rather than
hold this vote and we have to
really just call a spade a spade we
cannot in good faith blame the
republican party when house democrats
have a majority
now there is something to be said for
the fact that this court order came down
on the white house a month ago
and the white house waited until the day
before the house
adjourned to release a statement asking
on congress to extend the moratorium
conservative democrats that's the
funniest thing i've heard
in several days a handful of
conservative democrats who are those
exactly
yeah it's con every single democrat that
you
will talk to publicly will say you know
for example that
men can get pregnant so that that that's
conservative now
conservative democrats uh but this is a
perfect example
of the faux compassion
that you get from the left and even a
lot of people on the right who who
defend these sorts of policies
in eviction more time if we could put to
the side the fact that the cdc
does not have the authority to issue
such a proclamation in the first place
and it's it's kind of you know that's
the law okay the constitution it's sort
of hard to put that to the side
it's really important i would say if we
want to be a civilized
society um under under any kind of rule
of law then
then you can't really put the law to the
side but if we were to do that
and just talk about this thing on the
merits
this is horrific
um counterproductive
stupid morally deranged immoral
that you are telling people
that they must that they are required to
keep
people in their homes on their property
who are not
paying for the right to be there
that's what the government declared if
you're a landlord
um and there's someone on your on your
property
in your home who is refusing to pay you
refusing to compensate you at all you
must
continue to pay for them to live there
you got to pay their bills you're paying
the mortgage
you have to pay their rent for them
and allow them to stay on your property
that you know what that is that's
slavery that's forced labor
you're being forced by the government
to pay someone else's rent for them on
your property
it's like it's unthinkable and yet
millions of idiots will defend it on the
basis of compassion compassion for who
exactly
what about the person who owns the house
owns the property what about them
you're putting them underwater because a
big part of their financial plan here
is that you know they've got to pay the
mortgage on this property
and so to help them pay the mortgage
then that's that's that's why the
renters have to pay it's
you know just to be clear it's not
because they're mean landlords are it's
not because they're mean that they're
making you pay the rent it's because
they're providing you with something
with a service and you have to pay an
exchange but also
they need to pay very often they have
bills they have to they have to pay the
mortgage on this property
and if you don't chip in then now they
got to pay their own mortgage for their
home
plus this and however many many other
properties they own
so you are putting them in a financial
crisis
by not fulfilling your own obligations
and so yeah it's you know what it's
compassionate if we pretend
that the landlords don't exist that
they're not really people
speaking of forced labor and slavery if
we just pretend that they don't count as
people
then yeah it's perfectly compassionate
and and again the the land yeah there
are mean landlords out there
um i haven't i haven't rented in a long
time but
with my experience with landlords i had
some good experiences and some bad
experiences
um so there are mean landlords out there
there are bad landlords sure
but it's still their property they own
it
and you don't have a right to be there
if you're not paying for it
imagine think imagine thinking that
someone else some
stranger is in tight you are entitled to
stay on their property without
compensating them
you're entitled to it imagine walking
into someone else's house a stranger you
don't know them and saying i'm entitled
to be here no you can't kick me out
because that's what you're doing you're
squatting you're a squatter now
and you are trying to defend your right
to squat on this property without paying
it it really is infuriating and uh and
just so you know
yeah there are mean landlords out there
there are bad landlords but not every
landlord is some sort of
um fat cat you know in his in his uh
office sitting on his leather chair
stroking his his uh
his white cat smoking a cigar laughing
maniacally about all the poor people
he's about to
evict from his property okay that's
that's not the case that's
that's not how all landlords are in fact
most of them aren't you know a lot of
landlords they're just normal people
you want to know a situation that
happens a lot and this is how you know a
lot of um
single-family homes that are for rent
you could have just a normal family
that moves from a house and let's say
they're not able to sell it or they
decide they don't want to sell
and so and they move into a different
house and they rent out the house they
just moved out of
these are just normal middle-class
families yeah there are
plenty of normal middle-class families
middle-class people who are landlords
and but they don't count and now you're
saying oh you got to pay two mortgages
now
and if you're destitute because of it
that's your problem
and and also i i think it it
there's some bearing had this has some
bearing on this thing that
employers across the country
are begging for employees
okay there is not a crisis of jobs not
being available
employers are begging for people to come
work for them
offer you can get a signing bonus at
mcdonald's now
so who exactly are these uh
these millions of renters who simply
cannot pay their rent at all don't have
the ability can't get a job can't do
anything
while you've got employers begging
saying please come work for us we'll do
anything
but i know you have you have the right
to say no i don't want the job but i'm
just going to stay here
and i'm not going to pay for anything
and you have to pay for me to stay here
in your house
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content